[Music]
i'm just curious is anybody here on a
date i'm just curious you are okay
because if this is where you took her on
valentine's day you're not getting any
i'm just telling you
i promise you
take her to tavis smiley all right
that's the show where they actually yeah
oh tavis smiley will get you laid
that's their that's their motto now at
the show
all right i got some valentine's day
news for you uh this is good news papa
john's is offering a heart-shaped pizza
for valentine's day
isn't that nice
yeah it's it's for the wife who has
everything except a husband who knows
what a woman wants for valentine's day
got your heart-shaped pizza
i got this covered honey check it out
i ate half of it on the way home
it was a heart
i'm pretty much a hero yeah
for valentine's day time warner cable is
offering a special channel called ryan
gosling on demand
okay
ladies are happy but i'm sorry time
warner i'm a guy okay so call me when
you have robert pattinson on demand
all right
right fellas
who wants to hide
that guy wants to sleep with robert
pattinson
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yesterday uh what's going on in politics
yesterday newt gingrich rick santorum
and mitt romney all said that if elected
president they would eliminate porn
[Music]
in a related story president obama has
already been
unanimously
unanimous
yes we can
you see the unanimous reaction of the
crowd
eliminate points
never seen a crowd angrier about any
idea before
i know my people they like porn uh
you're gonna like this one
[Music]
one person believes me
[Applause]
one person went okay
check this out paramount pictures just
announced that they're gonna come out
with transformers four
yeah no you might like it in the new
movie transformers three transforms
itself into a good movie
[Applause]
why can't i do that but i can't make a
heart
uh the son of playboy founder hugh
hefner has been arrested on a charge of
domestic violence
hugh hefner's son yeah when he heard
this hugh hefner said son there's a
right way and a wrong way to disrespect
women
[Applause]
joke just does better with age
[Laughter]
reality star michelle duggar who has 19
children
now says she'd like to try and have more
kids
yeah coincidentally while she was given
the interview three more just fell out
of her
[Applause]
[Laughter]
they were fully clothed
[Laughter]
she's okay now but uh while vacationing
in south africa shakira was attacked by
a sea lion
she's fine but a sea lion attacked
shakira
yeah this is not surprising to animal
experts since the sea lion's natural
enemy is an amazing ass
it makes them crazy
let's pretend that one didn't happen
this is me just erasing
sea lion attacked her ass i know
jesus
i'm not helping much today am i boss
i just so want to be you right now
let's be nice over there oh it's
fantastic